beirut se ha levantado hoy así de vacía
y es que no es para menos el líbano es
el país con más casos de contagio por
coronavirus per cápita con una media de
4.500 contagios diarios entre una
población que no llega a 5 millones esto
ha llevado a un colapso total de los
hospitales en beirut por ejemplo la
ocupación de camas hospitalarias llega
al 97 por ciento mientras que en otras
ciudades ha llegado al cien por cien
esto ha llevado a que las autoridades
libanesas tomen medidas draconianas con
un confinamiento total y toques de queda
de 24 horas hasta el próximo 25 de enero
que podría prorrogarse los negocios e
instituciones públicas y privadas
permanecerán cerradas y los
supermercados y fruterías solo tendrán
servicio delivery el aeropuerto de
beirut permanecerá abierto pero todos
los viajeros que lleguen tendrán que
guardar una cuarentena de entre 3 días y
una semana en un hotel
las autoridades libanesas no han sabido
gestionar la pandemia y ahora los
libaneses están pagando los excesos de
las fiestas navideñas